ils ont traversé l'atlantique
l'équipe canadienne est arrivée à
trappes mardi midi jeudi
il affronte la suisse dans leur premier
match d'impro dans ce mondial maintenant
qu'on a survécu à la viande à l'auto je
trouve qu'elle est tres paraît beaucoup
moins grave maintenant l'effet devrait
bien le pavé sans qu'un peu de trac est
sûr qu'il ya toujours un peu arrivé ici
pis elles vont rappeler par deux passes
faire comprendre qu'ils quittaient donc
je dirais que ça c'est le premier stress
a déjoué mettant du 13 au 16 avril se
déroule la troisième édition du mondial
de l'improvisation celui des juniors
ils ont entre 15 et 19 ans il ya un truc
avec les juniors qu'on imagine pas c'est
qu'ils ne sont exclusivement que dans le
plaisir
c'est à dire que quel que soit le
résultat ils auront partager un vrai
moment ils auront 10 mercier à la fin
c'est beaucoup plus facile de proposer
ça à des enfants et sur le spectacle je
vous invite vraiment à venir les voir
les juniors finalement ils n'ont pas
grand chose à envier à
alors donné lundi l'équipe française
faisait son dernier entraînement
une équipe composée des meilleurs
trappistes de son bo ça se passe bien il
ya toujours un bon esprit une équipe
c'est ça aussi qui fait qui fait notre
force c'est qu'on est soudée solidaire
où on travaille comme il faut à
l'entraînement et
y a pas d'appréhension tout se passe
très bien pour l'instant c'est différent
parce qu'ils n'ont pas du tout le même
style de jeu que nous a parlé belle on a
à peu près le même jeu mais les suisses
et les québécois on n'a pas du tout le
même style de jeu mais on arrive quand
même à se comprendre ce qu'on a promise
quand même donc c'est ça qui nous
relient dimanche 16 janvier on connaîtra
le vainqueur de cette troisième édition
les québécois ont déjà deux trophées à
leur nom